the number is 1729
which is known as a hardy ramanujan
number in mathematical circles this is a
famous
number
so there was a
famous mathematician an indian
mathematician called ramanujan
now he started life quite
humbly he was a clerk
in india and he had no formal training
in mathematics however he worked as a
mathematician in his spare time he had
proven some things he sent these proofs
to cambridge a lot of the cambridge
mathematicians
just ignored it but
one cambridge mathematician
jeffrey hardy recognized something in
this now the proofs that he did were
actually things that were already well
known but he invited ramanujan over to
england and started to work with him and
ramanujan is now famous for us being one
of the great number theorists
unfortunately
the english weather and the english food
did not agree with ramanujan this is
round about the first world war england
is on rationing it's cold it's wet he
got
quite ill
jeffy hardy visited ramonesian in
hospital to make small talk he said
the taxi number that brought me here is
quite a boring number it's
1729. he he didn't couldn't think of
anything to say about this number and he
apologized to ramanujan saying i i can't
say this is not a very interesting
number i'm sorry about this number it
might be an important
there's nothing interesting about that
mammalian said no
there is it's the smallest number
that can be represented as a sum of two
cubes
in two different ways
1729
it is
12
12 cubed
plus
1 cubed
or you can write it as 10 cubed
plus 9 cubed
equals 1729.
now these sort of numbers are now known
as taxicab numbers for this reason now
there was one thing in the story which
is slightly wrong he should have said
the sum of the two cubes of positive
numbers positive integers because you
can find another solution to this if you
allow negative numbers in there
so jeffrey hardy told this story and i
think people tell this story to show how
brilliant ramanujan was how he could he
could just come up with that off the top
of his head i think the point jeffy
hardy was trying to make is no he wasn't
a genius ramanujan had come up with this
fact already in his previous research
this is something he studied something
he knew
so he wasn't
a genius he hadn't just come up with
that i think that's the point he was
trying to make if you allow negative
numbers then i can write down
6 cubed
plus
minus 5 cubed is the same as 4 cubed
plus
3 cubed
which is 91.
so this is the smallest number which is
the sum of two cubes
in two different ways if you allow
negative numbers and ramanujan thought
it was that because he only allowed for
positive numbers and you forgive him
because he was at their store at the
time